so if you have hypothyroidism i highly recommend
that you take cod liver oil let's talk about why
there are three main key nutrients that the
thyroid needs number one it needs iodine and
iodine makes up the thyroid molecule itself in
fact when we talk about t4 or t3 we're talking
about the number of iodine molecules okay then you
have selenium selenium is involved in an enzyme
that allows the conversion from t4 to t3
the active form of the thyroid hormone
so you need selenium it's a trace mineral so
about 80 percent of this conversion happens in
the liver and 20% happens in the kidney so you need
a healthy liver and you need a healthy kidney but
vitamin a is involved in this other hormone
called thyroid stimulating hormone which is
created from the pituitary and it's sent down to
the thyroid so it tells the thyroid what to do
and this whole chain of events is on a negative
feedback loop in fact the way they diagnose
hypothyroidism is with the thyroid stimulating
hormone if the thyroid stimulated hormone goes up
because there's no negative feedback coming back
that's one way they would diagnose a hypothyroid
case and when you have a vitamin a deficiency you
have a massive increase in thyroid stimulating
hormone and that can even increase the size of
the thyroid as in a goiter and actually decrease
the absorption of iodine so vitamin a is very
important in thyroid function so we have iodine
selenium and vitamin a now what is the best source
of vitamin a you might say carrots or spinach well
that will give you the precursor the beta carotene
which is good but the amount of conversion that's
going to happen is very very tiny okay because we
want the active form of vitamin a which is retinol
but it is also good for the eyes and the sinus
and many other things but the thyroid is another
benefit from vitamin a now you can get a lot of
vitamin a from liver in fact you might get too
much if you have too much liver so you'd
have to have just a small amount of liver
that's probably one of the best sources of vitamin
a if you like liver and you don't overdo it
i'm going to recommend cod liver oil because a
regular recommended amount if you're going to get
a supplement would give you about 150 percent
of vitamin a which is a little more than what
your body might need not too much just enough
and plus cod liver oil will give you vitamin d
it will also give you omega-3 fatty acids you
can also find retinol in butter grass-fed butter
eggs fatty fish cheese and other foods as well but
i wanted to emphasize the importance of vitamin a
for the thyroid all right thanks for watching hey
before you go real quick i have a course entitled
how to bulletproof your immune system it's a
free course i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here what about
strengthening your immune system that's what's
missing this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can tolerate
and resist your environment much better by
strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down
below check it out and get signed up today